joe biden calls peter ducey a stupid son
of a the u.s prepares to deploy 8
500 troops to europe and the supreme
court prepares to consider whether
affirmative action is still
constitutional i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
the bench bureau show is sponsored by
expressvpn protect your online privacy
today at expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first you've heard me talk a
lot about how you need life insurance
and of course that's not the only type
of insurance you need i mean let's say
that you're just living happily in a
city somewhere and all of a sudden you
look up into the sky and two superheroes
are just having a fist fight and boom
one of them goes flying directly through
your condo window well here's the thing
at that point you should have thought
about home insurance as well head on
over to policygenius.com
shapiro home answer a few questions
about yourself and your property policy
genius we'll show you price estimates
for policies that fit your search and
help you better understand your options
the policy genius team can look for ways
to save you more money and if they find
a better rate than what you're paying
right now they will switch you over for
free policy genius has saved customers
an average of one thousand two hundred
fifty dollars per year over what they
were paying for home and auto insurance
the policy junior team works for you not
the insurance companies so you can trust
them to offer unbiased help and advocate
for you every step until you are covered
policy genius does not add on extra fees
they don't sell your information to
third parties policy genius top notch
service has earned them thousands of
five star reviews across both google and
trust pilot and since 2014 policy genius
has helped over 30 million people shop
for insurance and placed 120 billion
dollars in coverage head on over to
policygenius.com shapirohome to get your
free home and auto insurance quotes see
how much you could save again that is
policygenius.com
shapiro home alrighty so yesterday the
president of the united states he's
having a bad day as all of his days are
lately he was considering the
possibility of a russian invasion of
ukraine plus the stock market was taking
an absolute roller coaster ride
yesterday it tumbled dramatically and
then it rose again dramatically but
according to bloomberg.com the stock
market has never been down this much 16
trading days into a year the s p 500 has
dropped 11 heading toward what would
count as a correction so far this year
that is the most on record at this
juncture according to bloomberg data
that goes back over nine decades though
drawdowns have been faster in prior
years before quick rebounds most notably
in
2009. the downturn comes as traders
brace for the federal reserve to tighten
monetary policy and a surge in u.s
treasury yields weighs on the outlook
for stocks a host of technical signals
also suggest more volatility may be
coming up ahead rich ross the technical
strategist at evercore isi he says the
fed pulled the punch bowl liquidity has
evaporated the s p and ndx broke below
their 200 dma for the first time since
the covet outbreak
a bear market down to the 3800 level is
likely for the s p 500 raw said given
the dramatic erosion of the technical
backdrop in conjunction with the highest
inflation tightest policy and most
uncertain political and geopolitical
condition in years so we went from this
is going to be a boom time to we could
be looking at a bear market really
really fast so joe biden yesterday he
came out and he spoke to the press and
then of course the press were ushered
out without being able to ask any
serious questions of him well on their
way out the press do what they usually
do which is they start yelling questions
to the president of the united states in
the hopes that he responds and peter
ducey caught a fish right he threw his
line in the water and he caught a fish
this time joe biden did respond to him
but it was on a hot mic and here's what
it sounded like
[Music]
okay so the actual question that ducey
asked was do you think inflation is a
political liability in the midterms and
biden responded it's a great asset more
inflation what a stupid son of a
and he said that about about peter ducey
so
a few things here that are kind of
hilarious first of all i don't care very
much about presidents saying things that
we all say about one another except they
happen to get caught on a mic as
somebody who's on a mic half of the day
i'm sure that there's audio of me saying
things on a hot mic that i really
wouldn't want to be public so i really
don't care too much about this however
the hypocrisy of the media here is
astonishing astonishing because you'll
remember that donald trump once called a
reporter
a son of a right at a rally this
is in september of 2017. and chris hayes
posted today the president called
american citizens who expressed their
political views sons of and then
yesterday after this happened with peter
ducey he tweeted literal lol
or how about brian stelter from cnn
the watchdog of the media he said
calling a journalist a son of a it
was wrong when trump was just a
candidate it's even worse now that he's
president because he did it again in
march of 2018. hey so what did he have
to say yesterday quote at the end of a
biden photo op when reporters shouted
queues hoping he'd respond fox's peter
ducey asked do you think inflation is a
political liability in the midterms
biden deadpan it's a great asset more
inflation what a stupid son of a
so it's totally fine with brian stelzer
this time around meanwhile
you'll recall that in 2020 donald trump
called somebody a name and here is joe
biden's tweet trump deflects legitimate
questions with attacks he bullies
members of the press instead of taking
responsibility for his failures his
efforts to undermine public confidence
in the integrity of reporting violate
our core values and threaten our very
system of government it was all pearl
clutching all the way down when it was
trump but when it's biden it's just a
genial old fellow who sometimes gets a
little bit cadre you know nbc's kelly
o'donnell who by the way is the incoming
president of the white house
correspondents association she tweet she
said yesterday on the air about biden
quote he does not like when questions
are asked about a subject other than the
planned event
oh so it's okay now got it because it
was joe biden so it's okay remember joe
biden said just a couple of months ago
that he would fire anybody who's
disrespectful to other reporters that
was after one of his one of his press
secretaries tj ducklow called up a
reporter and started yelling at her so
here was biden just a few months back
i'm not joking when i say this
if you're ever working with me and i
hear you treat another colleague with
disrespect
talk down to someone
i promise you i will fire you on the
spot
well sadly we cannot fire him on the
spot that that is too bad apparently
biden did call peter ducey on monday
evening
and ducey said after years of clips of
the president me mixing it up on the
campaign trail and during the transition
here at the white house within about an
hour of that exchange he called my cell
phone he said it's nothing personal pal
we went back and forth and we were
talking about just kind of moving
forward i made sure to tell him i'm
always going to try to ask something
different than what everybody else is
asking he said you got to and that's a
quote from the president so i'll keep
doing it
and um when asked if biden actually
apologized he said he cleared the air
and i appreciated it we had a nice call
um and uh that is not an apology so joe
biden did not in fact call to apologize
for calling peter ducey a son of a
he just said it's nothing personal by
the way it did make it into the white
house transcript which is one of the
great transcripts he had in in american
history that is right there in the white
house transcript it's like george
washington or abraham lincoln basically
president biden now again what this
comes back to is a basic perception of
politics that the left has just gotten
wrong and many on the right got it wrong
too which is that donald trump was the
murderer of american politics not the
coroner i've said this a thousand times
donald trump was elected president
because he stumbled upon the body of
american politics it was still warm and
there was a knife directly in its back
and then he crouched over it and looked
at the knife in the back and everybody
went he did it it was him he must have
murdered politics
nope it was like this before it'll be
like this afterward again joe biden is
not all that different from donald trump
he's
just more used to washington d.c
the belief that donald trump was a
difference in kind in terms of being
rude and nasty to people is ridiculous
and barack obama was a pretty prickly
fellow and joe biden has been routinely
prickly with people for years you
remember that on the campaign trail he
literally called one of his constituents
fat
and there's a bernie sanders supporter
who is asking him questions and goes
look fat you're never gonna have a
push-up conscious right now fat man you
want to do it fat guy it's just he's a
ridiculous person
okay but again it's the media's double
standard here that is truly astonishing
when joe biden does it it is perfectly
appropriate and totally cool and when it
is anybody else who is republican then
it's because they're bad and mean and
it's the death of democracy and
democracy is at stake and the free press
is about to be trampled upon
it's amazing how many reporters made a
mint off of the period in which the free
press was supposedly in existential
danger meanwhile you've got joe biden
holding a press conference once every
300 days
and then yelling at anybody who asked
him a question but the press is
definitely not in danger from joe biden
okay meanwhile
the situation continues to deteriorate
over in eastern europe according to the
uk daily mail president biden said on
monday that he and european leaders had
total unanimity about the situation in
ukraine although he declined to provide
more details on what they agreed upon
now that is a switch in language from
joe biden who is a wild incompetent
remember that just a few days ago he had
a press conference in which he announced
that the europeans were completely split
over what to do if russia were to just
walk into eastern ukraine
which is true the germans are very
conciliatory toward the russians because
the russians are shipping them natural
gas the french are very conciliatory
towards the russians because the french
are the french so none of that is a
major surprise however that was sort of
something you're supposed to keep under
wraps you're not supposed to say
publicly that nato was split over
putin's action because that gives him
room to operate so yesterday
the pentagon announced that the united
states would be alerting 8 500 u.s
troops
to be prepared to deploy not to ukraine
to surrounding countries
now here's the thing vladimir putin
isn't going to invade the surrounding
countries he's not invading latvia he's
not he's not invading lithuania or
estonia or any of the countries that are
actual members of nato he's not going to
invade
all he wants to do is shift ukraine from
being an independent country into being
a country in the russian sphere of
influence that is what he desires
ukraine was not about to enter nato by
the way ukraine tried to enter nato back
in 2008 2009. that didn't happen and
then there was the orange revolution in
and that ended with the ouster of victor
yanukovych who was the then ukrainian
president he was sort of a russian plant
and he was replaced by a more western
friendly government but it was never on
the table that ukraine was about to
enter nato so when putin says that he
wants a guarantee the ukraine will never
be able to to enter nato what he is
really saying is we want ukraine back in
our sphere of influence and that means
us occupying certain parts of ukraine
and putting putting such heavy pressure
on ukraine to kowtow to our demands that
they just do so that they no longer
associate with the west at all here is
john kirby however announcing that us
units were preparing to deploy
secretary austin has placed a range of
units in the united states on a
heightened preparedness to deploy which
increases our readiness to provide
forces if nato should activate the nrf
or if other situations develop
all told
the number of forces that the secretary
has placed on heightened alert uh comes
up to about 8 500 personnel
so
that is uh the response is we're going
to put more personnel in the surrounding
areas but without any actual
ability to stop putin from going into
ukraine now i know there are a lot of
people on the right who have been saying
that they don't care whether putin goes
into ukraine here's the point you know i
don't really care about ukraine per se
either except that ukraine is a country
that has been trending toward the west
by every available poll this is a
country that is trending toward the west
which is a good thing and resting
countries away from the sphere of
influence of a nefarious dictator like
vladimir putin is definitely a good
thing if you don't stop nefarious
dictators early they tend to get worse
they do not tend to get better
this belief system that
you can sort of treat
every foreign policy issue in isolation
as opposed to part of a grand strategy
is negated by the fact that our enemies
don't treat it like that our enemies are
not like every single foreign policy
decision is separate from every other
foreign policy decision as part of a
grand strategy russia is extremely
aggressive on its borders because it
wishes to re-establish the ussr's its
sphere of interest
that that's the goal and china is doing
the same thing so when we allow for
vacuums to occur then those vacuums are
filled and then all those countries that
we dislike all the countries that for
example unleash pandemics on the globe
that kill several million people and
attempt to twist american corporations
in their favor those regimes get
stronger like china
regimes like russia start to exert more
pressure and influence inside europe
which makes it more difficult for us to
do business with europe to stop china
for example all of these issues are
interlinked the attempt to disconnect
all foreign policy issues is an exercise
in in silliness and failure in any case
joe biden led a meeting with leaders
from the eu france germany italy poland
and the uk
it lasted about 90 minutes biden spoke
from the white house's situation room it
was closed to press but the white house
posted a photo of it to its social media
accounts apparently the group discussed
their joint efforts to deter further
russian aggression against ukraine
including preparations to impose massive
consequences and severe economic costs
on russia for such actions as well as to
reinforce security on nato's eastern
flank
nato secretary general janza stoltenberg
said the leaders agreed there would be
severe cost to russia if moscow invaded
ukraine
he said we agree any further aggression
by russia against ukraine will have
severe costs a downing street
spokeswoman said should a further
russian incursion into ukraine happen
allies must enact swift retributive
responses including an unprecedented
package of sanctions and that leaders
resolve to continue coordinating closely
on any such response she added the
leaders agreed on the importance of
international unity in the face of
growing russian hostility the prime
minister underlined the real human cost
of any russian aggression and the need
to take all steps within our power to
prevent that outcome
they agreed the international community
should not tolerate any action which
undermines ukrainian sovereignty the
prime minister outlined the steps the uk
has taken to increase russia ukraine's
defensive capacity he emphasized the
need to support ukraine's defenses
against the full spectrum of malign
russian activity apparently emmanuel
macron the french president will be
speaking with russian president vladimir
putin and the ukrainian president
vladimir zolensky in the coming days
and apparently president macron
expressed his deep concern over the
situation and the need to work
collectively to de-escalate it quickly
the de-escalation must involve strong
and credible warnings to russia
requiring constant coordination among
european partners and allies as well as
they stepped up dialogue with russia
which we are in the process of
conducting said the readout of the call
from the elysee palace
so
that is where things stand right now
hopefully this is enough to deter the
russians from walking into ukraine
right now apparently 50 000 troops are
being considered for deployment into
lithuania estonia and latvia all of
which are nato countries there are
already 35 000 us troops stationed in
germany they're already about 12 500
troops stationed in italy
and of course there are russian troops
in belarus that are going to take part
in exercises beginning february 10th and
there are a bunch of russian troops that
are stationed in crimea as well about 30
000 troops stationed illegally in crimea
as well as the russian black sea fleet
based in sevastopol
so
you know the the
controversy over over ukraine continues
to marinate and we will obviously keep
an eye on it the people of ukraine for
their part are preparing for the
possibility of a significant incursion
by the russians we'll get to that in
just one moment first let's talk about
the greatest office chair so as you can
tell i'm not in my office right now
right and that means i'm not sitting in
the greatest of all chairs which is why
i got to tell you not that comfortable
the most comfortable of all chairs a
chair made by the hands of the angels
the ex-chair the first moment i said in
my ex chair my body immediately said yes
this is what a real office chair is
supposed to feel like i never looked
forward to seeing an office chair before
but then i got to the extra can your
current office chair give you a massage
while you are working my ex chair can
can your current office chair heat up or
cool down my extra can do that too it's
all in the lmx massage and temperature
regulation exclusively designed and made
for xchair and once you feel the
customized support of extra's patented
dynamic variable lumbar support your
back will never be happy in any other
chair ever ever again try the x chair
yourself risk free for 30 days once you
realize how much better your chair
should be you will never go back i
promise go to exterior shapiro.com that
is the letter x chair shapiro.com
xchairshapiro.com or call eight four
four four x chair for a hundred bucks
off your order x chair has a 30 day
guarantee of complete comfort you can
finance your purchase for as little as
30 bucks a month exchair shapiro.com go
check them out right now meanwhile
over in ukraine the the normal ukrainian
citizens are preparing their kids for
the possibility of an actual open battle
with the russians according to the wall
street journal computer whiz daniello
kovchun has taught his children to
handle a pistol confessioner roman
nabashiniak is training colleagues to
run his business so he can focus on
fighting russians bar owner vitaly
krishenko keeps his gas tank full in
case he needs to get out fast ukraine
has struggled to maintain a sense of
stability since it's fully established
itself as a sovereign country in 1991
they've been at war since 2014 but with
one hundred thousand russian troops
gathering nearby threatening europe's
biggest land war since the 1940s people
there say something different this time
it became kind of normal to say what
again said mr kavjun at 46 years old on
the other hand i tend to be panicky i
think it's gonna be a nightmare like
syria that's the only thing russians can
do so the theory is that this turns into
like a full-scale guerrilla war that if
the russians wander across the border
and the ukrainian army is unable to hold
them back people will basically start
doing guerrilla attacks on russian
forces and it will end up looking like
afghanistan except right in the middle
of europe which does have the
possibility for syria spillover because
obviously the the ukrainian rebels would
be backed by outside forces the russians
could respond in kind it could get
really really ugly
all of this is because europe has failed
to stop the russians earlier always and
forever
ukrainian officials have in recent days
urged people to remain calm fearing
russia could try to take advantage of
panic
officials complain that us warnings that
russia appears ready to invade will
provoke alarm prominent ukrainians are
posting advice on facebook with a
hashtag in ukrainian meaning
we are ready including a child
psychologist describing how to prepare
kids for emergencies like bombings and
fires and how to explain war without
traumatizing young ones
so far this has been working there have
been no bank runs the currency has only
lost little value against the us dollar
however
everybody is sort of prepared for things
to get much much uglier in ukraine in
the very near future meanwhile it's just
worthwhile noting here that all of this
really was precipitated by the fact that
joe biden decided to pull out of
afghanistan for no apparent reason
when again when the west creates a
vacuum the less enemies decide to move
gensake is trying to call that russian
propaganda it's not russian propaganda
it's reality here's jensaki
they point to the u.s withdrawal from
afghanistan as evidence that the united
states cannot be counted on how does the
united states respond to that and has
the afghanistan withdrawal complicated
diplomacy in this regard
uh it is not in our experience we the
president ended a 20-year war uh in
afghanistan something he had talked
about consistently doing for some time
as he was running for president and even
before then so what i would say to that
is that sounds like the old russian
propaganda playbook something we've
talked about in the past and i'd
encourage anyone to be mindful of that
everything i don't like is russian
propaganda seems to be the formula from
this white house meanwhile by the way
isis is back so if there's anything else
that the bible administration can set on
fire they're avidly looking to do so
according to the new york times fighting
between a kurdish-led militia backed by
the united states and isis militants
spread on tuesday to neighborhoods
around an embattled prison in
northeastern syria that is at the center
of the biggest confrontation between the
american military and isis in three
years the us military joined the fight
on monday to back its allies and the
kurdish-led syrian democratic forces
against isis days after the militant
group attacked a makeshift prison in the
city of hasaka in an attempt to free
isis fighters held there the us has
launched airstrikes and provided
intelligence and ground troops in
bradley fighting vehicles are helping to
cordon off the prison isis now controls
about one quarter of the prison is
holding hostages including child
detainees
the us-led coalition said the fight has
become the biggest battle between the
u.s and isis since the group lost the
last piece of territory it controlled in
syria in 2019 so that's good news isis
is also on the move i mean is there
anything else that joe biden can screw
up around here i mean seriously he's
just looking
i mean the answer is yes taiwan right
the answer is always yes there's always
more things for joe biden to screw up
but if you're america's enemies at this
point why wouldn't you move seriously
what is the convincing case for not
moving you have a split america on the
domestic front you have a president of
the united states who has not taken the
measures necessary to deter our enemies
from acting you have the russians and
the chinese and the iranians holding
joint naval exercises
why exactly would they not move if they
could
by the way this is having predictable
impacts as well some good some bad the
predictable impacts are that countries
now considering whether to enter the
western sphere of influence or whether
to join with china or russia are having
to seriously consider
because the west is just not a reliable
ally
it's also true that you're starting to
see non-aligned countries beginning to
sort of come together in their own block
right that's what you're seeing with the
abraham accords as countries begin to
see that the united states is making
overtures to iran all the other
countries are like well we better ally
among ourselves because otherwise there
is not much that we can do in the face
of iranian aggression
alrighty in just a second we'll get to
the continued panic over omicron from
the left they just won't let it's a
natural mindset it's an actual psychotic
mindset for some people now first when
you do anything in life there's one way
to do it and then maybe there's a
smarter way to do it you might already
be investing in cryptocurrency did you
know you can trade bitcoin ethereum over
80 other cryptocurrencies in a
tax-advantaged ira so as you know i'm a
big fan of cryptocurrencies
cryptocurrencies are pretty volatile
right now but i think that these are
long-term plays you buy some bitcoin and
you hold it for a long time that's what
i'm doing i mean i'm personally doing
that i have a bunch of money in bitcoin
have a bunch of money in ethereum with
an alto crypto ira you can trade crypto
like bitcoin and avoid or defer the
taxes get into investing in crypto do it
in a tax advantage retirement account
alto's crypto ira is the easy way to get
crypto into an ira trade all you want
without the tax header create an account
in just a few minutes invest with as
little as 10 bucks there are no set up
charges secure trading 24 7 through
alto's integration with coinbase 80 plus
coins are available including bitcoin
ethereum and cardano they've got
industry-leading security the advanced
encryption standard for wallets and
private keys and multiple ways to fund
your account you can make a cash
contribution you can transfer cash from
an existing ira or roll over an old 401k
open an auto crypto account with as
little as 10 bucks just go to
altoira.com
ben that is altoira.com
start investing in cryptocurrency today
go to altoira.com
ben okay meanwhile
the left will not let go of covet panic
they won't let go of it it does not
matter by the way that the who is
essentially saying that we may have
reached the end of this pandemic
effectively speaking it does not matter
the reason it does not matter is because
people have gotten invested in this
thing now they cannot allow it to end
they have to just
no matter what they have to continue it
okay for a perfect example check out the
reaction to
barry weiss and and bill maher so
barry weiss is i would say a centrist
liberal right she's somebody who has a
lot of liberal ideas about social policy
as well as as social welfare spending
for example she tends to be much more
hawkish on foreign policy but when it
comes to covid barry has had an
awakening right barry used to be like a
lot of people living in big cities very
coveted fearful and barry came out over
the weekend and she was like uh no i'm
i'm done with this right my life i've
already been vaccinated everybody i know
has omicron i'm not doing this any
longer and people went nuts
according to michelle goldberg at the
new york times weiss described making an
all-out effort to avoid covet early on
and then we were told you got the
vaccine you get the vaccine you get back
to normal and we haven't gotten back to
normal and it's ridiculous at this point
and the audience was cheering right
because this is true even folks on the
left are tired of this they are sick of
this bill maher said the same thing
okay but the left cannot accept this as
an answer and so whoopi goldberg
yesterday she got very angry at bill
maher for pointing out that many people
have been living normally in the united
states for a year at this point here's
whoopi goldberg slapping a bill maher
nobody on the planet really wants to go
through this this is not something we're
doing because it's you know sexually
gratifying this is what we're doing to
protect our families and you don't have
to do it but stay away from everybody
because if you're the one who's
not paying attention
and you're coughing and sneezing you
don't want to
then stay out of the public man this is
not nobody wants this
i don't want it and i think he's
forgetting that people are still at risk
who cannot get vaccinated people who
can't get little kids under the age of
five yeah or people with health
conditions how dare you be so flippant
man
how dare you be so flippant well i have
a question do vaccines work or they not
work to prevent hospitalization and
death okay so do we all wear masks and
stay home like forever when we are
asymptomatic from the flu is that is
that how this works typically speaking
i mean but but that is what whoopi
goldberg is asking of everybody
and yes there is a perverse
there's a perverse sense from a lot of
these folks that they are enjoying this
yes it is i'm not saying it is sexually
gratifying but it is it is mentally and
emotionally gratifying to a lot of
people to be living like this it makes
them feel morally superior it makes them
feel like they are part of a common
cause well you're not part of a common
cause because you're still going to work
whoopi goldberg
you're still seeing people you're still
going out and doing things
like all of the people who are claiming
that they're still walking around masked
and that they're in no close contact
with other people i think the vast
majority of them are lying
and because the fact is that they don't
want to live like this on a personal
level but they want everybody else to
live like this and they want to be able
to lecture everybody else they want this
to be the new normal they want this to
be the new permanent some of them are
even clearer than whippy goldberg sarah
haynes also of the view she literally
says she might not feel comfortable ever
again without a mask
and therefore you must mask
okay not she's got her own weird
hang-ups about she's gonna wear her mask
the rest the rest of her life it's that
you have to wear a mask the rest of your
life because she has a weird hang up
here we go
i think there's a prudence we've learned
with the mask the hand sanitate
hand sanitizing that kind of like 911
with flying is always going to be here
now there's a new normal in the
beginning when at post 911 people didn't
want to fly and the security measures
felt like uh how do we do this you know
and now it's the norm i think some of
the things we've learned in this
pandemic are going to stay the same i
may never write a subway again without a
mask i may never go indoors to big
crowds and never feel comfortable
without a mask and that's up to me to do
that
that is up to you to do that but that's
not what you want you want it to be up
to everybody to do that you know this is
the natural health consequent of the
entirely ridiculous world view that your
feelings get to decide everybody else's
thoughts
this is a big thing on the left there's
a there's a philosophy
that's been termed by by a philosopher
named robert bella expressive
individualism and the idea is that the
true you is what lives inside your
feelings it is not how you react to
society or to the people around you the
true you is your feelings and because
the true you is your feelings anytime
your feelings are affected by anyone
else this is an attack on you now we see
this mostly when it comes to sexual
proclivities that or or gender
proclivities that we are all supposed to
reflect your opinion of you right you
call yourself a woman and you're a man
we're all supposed to do that so that
you feel better on the inside otherwise
it's an attack on you but now they're
taking this to the next level with
health so now you have sarah haynes
saying i feel uncomfortable in public
without wearing a mask
but you refuse to go along with me
that's an attack on me well sarah haynes
seems to be a healthy human being right
she seems to have been vaccinated 97
times so what exactly is she worried
about and the answer is that as long as
she feels that her health might be
affected
then this means that we are all supposed
to act in conjunction with that by the
way the reason that everybody is getting
uptight now when they weren't all
uptight about taking these measures at
the beginning of the pandemic because
here's the deal you can go back and
listen all the way at the beginning of
the pandemic i said masks might be
necessary i said that social distancing
is probably a good idea when we didn't
know how deadly this was and who it
affected i was with my parents all the
time at the beginning of the pandemic my
parents were 65 so that means that we
were basically bubbled we were taking a
lot of precautions as well
and then the data became clear and then
we got the vaccines which made things
much clearer and then we got omicron
which made things even clearer than that
if you didn't change your opinion based
on the data
then that's because you didn't care
about the data and these people don't
care about the data so michelle goldberg
over at the new york times she says the
desperate desire to get back to normal
is understandable what's odd is seeing
the absence of normality as a political
betrayal instead of an epidemiological
curveball
but it is a political betrayal because
the political players in our society
said we will follow the data and then we
will give you best guidance but they're
not doing that they're doing precisely
the opposite they're pretending that
omicron doesn't evade vaccination in
terms of infection they're still
pretending that boosters are going to
stop omicron not going to happen they're
still pretending that masks are going to
stop omicron not going to happen
none of that crap is
happening
but according to michelle goldberg
the reason things aren't normal isn't
that power mad public health officials
one went back on their promises it's
because a new coronavirus variant
emerged that overwhelmed hospitals and
through schools and many industries into
chaos because not everyone has the
luxury of being insouciant about
infection okay the the vast majority of
people who are quote unquote having the
luxury of being incensed about infection
okay that's the vast majority of the
population because they all got
vaccinated had prior immunity from
having gotten this thing already or
they're healthy to begin with
but here's here's the real key to
michelle goldberg's piece over the new
york times this is the key she says even
with omicron around there's a fair bit
of normality available especially if you
don't have kids here in new york city
restaurants bars nightclubs theaters are
generally open those shows are closing
at the last minute when cast members
fall ill you can have a party or go on
vacation what you can't do is force
other people whose vulnerabilities might
be greater than your own to agree with
your risk assessments and join you in
moving on while the pandemic still rages
but you've moved on michelle goldberg
yorig is from what i understand a single
lady living in new york
normality exists for the people who are
trying to cram this down listen to again
her description of what life is like in
new york there's normality available if
you don't have kids because you can
still go to restaurants and bars and
nightclubs and theaters if you're
vaccinated and you don't have well what
about all those people who do have kids
what about all those people with prior
immunity
again this is disconnected from the data
but they refuse to accept that they've
disconnected from the data specifically
because they enjoy pushing this they
enjoy the unearned sense of moral
superiority here's mehdi hassan doing
the same thing ripping into barry weiss
we haven't gotten back to normal
and it's ridiculous at this point
oh it's ridiculous is it on the same day
that weiss and mar were complaining
about our obsessive focus on covert 19
and urging us all to move on from the
pandemic three thousand five hundred and
six americans died from kobe that's a
higher death hold on on 9 11. in fact
that's the highest covered death since
last winter and one of the deadliest
days of the pandemic so far and it isn't
just deaths hospitals are full three out
of four of them nationwide are under
high or extreme stress in utah they're
hospitalizing unvaccinated under fives
including babies and look the people who
should be complaining right now are our
overworked and burned out healthcare
workers but no it's never them moaning
or whinging about the pandemic it's the
barry weisses and bill mahers and tucker
carlson's of this world
does he have a solution
does he have any solution
of course he doesn't have a solution
because there's no solution it's hit
everywhere it spikes we're already on
the downside of the spike and death
trails infection
the reason that our death toll is high
right now is not because omicron is
extremely deadly it's because it's
extremely infectious and it evades all
of the things that you guys are using as
your mitigating factors
we've seen massive spikes in places
including new york including vermont
like some of the most
vaccinated places on the planet
but again if they just try to scare you
then the idea is that if you refuse to
be scared or if you try to actually
define your own risk
with reference to your own particular
health scenario then you are the bad guy
you're the bad guy
because these are the experts and they
know what's best for you and unless
things are imposed on you you are evil
everything not compulsory is
forbidden everything not compulsories
forbidden should be the theme song for
these guys jen saki did the same thing
yesterday she said public health
officials not parents make the best
decisions for their kids really name my
kids jen
like seriously can do you know my kids
you don't know my kids you don't know
their health conditions you don't know
how many times they've had the flu in
the past couple of years
you don't know if they've had omicron
you don't know any of that stuff
but apparently she and dr foucher are
going to define for my kids what is best
for my kids insane here's shinsaki doing
this again
who does the president think knows best
for
students school board members or parents
well the parent the president believes
that uh public health officials have the
best guidance
on what we can all do to protect
ourselves
okay but that's not the question the
question is whether public health
officials give their guidance and then
parents get to assess for their kids
what is right i've wanted my kids on
madison school since the beginning of
the year you know why because a vast
number of kids are not dying from this
disease
nearly all the kids who are getting this
are completely fine
thank god
but
but again we were supposed to listen to
dr fauci about all this and if you
refuse to do this and this be it's
because you're bad and babies are being
hospitalized or something according to
medicine
by the way dr fauci is still out there
trying to uh trying to
push his own brand
dead giveaway as to whether someone is
an asshat or not is whether in all of
their interviews they have a great
picture of themselves behind them and uh
in in half of fouchy's interviews he
does here was dr yesterday being asked
about the missed messaging coming from
the public health establishment whether
this is undercut the credibility of the
public health establishment here he was
yesterday
information and communication around
boosters has been really problematic
even today the pivoting of communication
around what it means to be vaccinated
that is really difficult for people and
it's causing people to not go get the
booster how do you fix that yeah
well you try to be clear
and concise and articulate
what's happened so far
well i'm not gonna comment on that
of course he's not going to comment on
that the one thing he won't do is walk
away right he has completely blown out
his own credibility by taking every
available position during this pandemic
but he's definitely not going to walk
away that's all anthony fouch knows i
mean why should he's earning the best
salary in the entire federal government
this is too important this is the kind
of thing that i've devoted my entire
career
but certainly over the last 40 plus
years
in public health science and medicine
and we are in a crisis right now and
there's no chance i'm going to walk away
from this
of course not why would he again that's
a big check he's taken home
also it would completely undermine his
entire history of claiming to be the
great savior when it comes to medicine
by the way we still have our public
health officials trying to cram down on
parents what they ought to do about
masking school kids even though the data
are very clear and they are in according
to the washington post seven school
boards in virginia have now sued to stop
governor glenn youngkin's mask optional
order on the day it takes effect the
school boards led by the board for
fairfax county public schools the
largest most prominent district in the
state argue that young king's order
violates the virginia constitution that
filed a lawsuit asking for an immediate
injunction barring enforcement of the
order which seeks to leave masking
decisions to parents contributing
federal health guidance and the masking
mandates most virginia school districts
have maintained throughout the covid
pandemic
so they just will not let this go
despite the fact that they have no data
no data to back their case alrighty
coming up we'll get to the supreme court
accepting a very controversial case on
school
race-based admissions first let's talk
about your gas price so gas costs too
much money right now i think you all
know who to blame
let's go brandon but in any case you
need to start saving money on your gas
right now so why not check out the get
upside app it is free my listeners are
making up to 25 cents for every gallon
of gas every time they fill up just
download that free get upside app in the
app store or google play right now use
promo code shapiro get a bonus 25 cents
per gallon on your first fill up that is
up to 50 cents cash back do not pay full
price of the pump anymore get cash back
using get upside just download the app
for free use promo code shapiro get up
to 50 cents per gallon cash back on your
very first tank of gas
some people who drive a lot are making
as much as two to three hundred dollars
a year in cash back and there's no catch
the cash back gets added directly to
your account you can cash out anytime
it's your bank account paypal or an
egift card for amazon and other brands
just download that free get upside app
use promo code shapiro to get up to 50
cents per gallon cashback on your very
first tank of gas that is promo code
shapiro again get that get upside app
today promo code shapiro will get you 50
cents per gallon cashback on your very
first tank of gas and then 25 cents per
gallon on every tank of gas after that
alrighty we will get to the supreme
court now considering whether schools
can simply basically bar asians and jews
first if you haven't heard of adam
carolla's new daily wire exclusive
comedy series truth yeller you need to
get started in the next episode which
airs this thursday adam gets
controversial he mocks hunter biden and
the way our overlords are attempting to
crate train your kids tj miller of
silicon valley deadpool big hero 6 and
more joins adam to drop some comedy gold
and prove he knows how to identify a
grandma killer so head on over to
dailywire.com subscribe use code miller
for 25 off your membership look out for
the new episode with tj miller dropping
this thursday also the daily wire we
work to bring you the truth which is why
we've launched our own publishing wing
dw books and we are proud to be
publishing two books that are actively
fighting the less monopoly on
storytelling the first is 12 seconds in
the dark by sergeant mattingly the book
is the true story of what really
happened the night of the tragic brianna
taylor shooting mattingly is a 20-year
police veteran he takes readers inside
his department's response debunks the
lies that have recklessly been shared
with the public you'll remember that
this book was basically barred by simon
schuster for distribution
the this book which was telling the
truth about what exactly happened during
the briana taylor shooting which has
been used as a cause celeb by the left
to attack police departments all around
the country
this book tells the truth about what
exactly went down that night it was
barred by simon schuster because of
protests from its employees we here at
dw books we're not going to cower in the
face of intimidation which is why we're
proud to bring out that book dw books is
also publishing fiery but mostly
peaceful by julio rosas who pulls back
the curtain and sets the record straight
on the black lives matter riots that
broke out across the country in 2020.
the media lied about it julio actually
covered it rosas who was reporting it
from the ground gives his first-hand
experience at the blm riots and exposes
the media's attempts to convince
americans that the fatal and destructive
riots were actually fiery but mostly
peaceful i'm really grateful to have
these brave truth tellers on board over
at tw books can't wait for you to hear
their stories both are available for
pre-order right now on amazon or
anywhere you buy books online you're
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
alrighty so meanwhile the supreme court
has now said that it will decide whether
to prohibit the use of race-conscious
admissions in higher education
according to the wall street journal
it's agreeing to consider challenges to
policies at both harvard and the
university of north carolina the court
in a brief written order on monday said
it would consider a pair of challenges
by a group called students for fair
admissions it's been led by the
conservative legal activist edward blum
they sued both schools on the same day
in 2014.
the lawsuit against harvard alleged that
the school uses quota-like racial
balancing tactics that artificially
raised the standards of admission for
asian-american applicants in violation
of federal civil rights law the
challengers alleged asians were admitted
at a lower rate than whites even though
their overall academic scores were
better harvard rejected the claims of
discrimination said it only considered
race in a flexible way as one factor
among many in building diverse classes
of students well why is it even being
considered as a factor at all
couldn't you just look at for example
life challenges without looking at race
why is race considered a life challenge
in the united states explicitly
and why is it even a matter of inquiry
for schools to determine that your race
is a relevant factor in whether you
ought to be admitted to a school
i mean it is a pretty overt racism when
students get in with 200 points less on
the sats than this asian student over
here just because this asian student
happens to be asian
this is what they used to do to jews at
colleges in the united states now
they're doing it to asians in the united
states it's absurd on its face it is
wild racism from the left and yet the
left continues to double down on this
because obviously asians are a supposed
model minority according to the left
whereas black americans are indubitably
put upon and therefore black americans
only need a 1300 or a 1200 to get into
harvard whereas asians needed 19 000 to
get on
they need to get a 19 000 on their sats
in order to get into harvard
under the trump administration the
justice department actually supported
that lawsuit the biden era department
abandoned that position and offered
support for harvard in a legal brief
last month urging the supreme court to
turn away the challenge
the lawsuit against the university of
north carolina was similar to the
harvard allegations but added claims
that the flagship public university in
chapel hill violated the constitution's
guarantee of equal protection
so with a private school the challenge
is going to be that it violates the
civil rights act with the public school
the the challenge is going to be that it
violates the 14th amendment the
challengers allege that the school
unlawfully factored students race into
the admissions process favoring black
hispanic and native american applicants
and even caused them harm by inviting
them into classrooms for which they
weren't prepared which is true
the the thurnstroms
who used to write for the atlantic they
documented very well the the phenomenon
of misalignment in which students are
admitted to schools that they actually
are not prepared for and then they tend
to flunk out of those schools at a
higher rate
unc and court papers says it has made
progress on diversity but continues to
face challenges in admitting
underrepresented minorities now the
truth is that supreme court precedent
here has been ridiculous because supreme
court said that for some reason
diversity is in and of itself a public
good i'm not sure why they never really
explained why diversity is a public good
if they said that a wide range of human
experiences is worthwhile to pursue in
student body settings that might be
better but when they say racial
diversity itself is some sort of public
good there's no reason why that should
be
also the diversity standards tend to be
wildly inaccurate so for example if you
have a classroom full of black students
this is considered diverse if you have
an entire classroom filled with asian
students it's considered not diverse
enough
nobody can explain why
both are monochrome but only one type of
monochrome is diverse according to the
left here is jen saki however trying to
defend the biden administration pushing
over racism on nation against asian
americans
we strongly believe this administration
in the benefits of diversity in higher
education and we take very seriously our
commitment to advancing equity and equal
opportunity for historically underserved
populations
okay but they're going to have to
explain why this is capable of violating
constitutional precept now the fact the
supreme court is even considering it
again is really interesting because in
2016 the court ruled that the university
of texas in austin's process passed
constitutional muster despite the fact
that it took race into account that was
an absurd ruling it was a 4-3 court and
justice anthony kennedy was the deciding
justice in that particular case he
joined the left of course ginsburg
breyer and sotomayor saying universities
are defined by intangible qualities
which make for greatness he said
considerable deference is owed to a
university in defining those intangible
characteristics well they seem pretty
tangible when you're barring asians just
to be fair it seems like kind of
tangible to the asian student who scored
a 1580 on his s.a.t then got barred
because he happened to be asian
but this is something that the left
loves to push this is one of their
favorite things by the way they don't
just want it to apply at colleges
because nothing that starts in college
ends in college for the left
the washington post editorial board has
an entire piece today about how every
company in america should be forced to
quote unquote diversify its boardroom
quote the securities and exchange
commission last summer approved a
proposal by nasdaq to require the most
boards of directors among the exchanges
approximately three thousand companies
include at least one woman as well as at
least one person of color and or one
lgbtq person
nasdaq's initiatives was groundbreaking
for u.s securities exchange it's not
very novel in other contexts california
already had laws mandating the public
companies headquartered in state have
women and by 2023 members of
underrepresented communities on their
boards
many european countries require more
gender diversity than the nasdaq even
envisions
but this is good according to the
washington post it's very encouraging
because more progress is needed luckily
there are plenty of incentives for firms
to make such strides and not just
political and public pressure okay so
here's the deal these companies
all they do is they find some sort of
placeholder and they just add seeds to
the board and then they put that
placeholder on the board to ensure that
they are not sued by the government but
the reality of course is that businesses
are going to continue to run it's an
absurdity on its face and it's very very
silly
but again it is it is unearned moral
superiority of the left that is the
deciding factor here even when that
means active discrimination against more
qualified applicants in college or
against members of the board who ought
to be there as opposed to being
leveraged onto the board by the
government
the government has no business in this
area and by the way neither does nasdaq
or the s or or the or the new york stock
exchange
it's ridiculous
the solution that companies are going to
find is to have a useless board member
that they add and pay a little bit of a
salary or never go public in the first
place that will be the actual answer to
this problem alrighty we'll be back here
later today with an additional hour of
content in the meantime go check out our
newest podcast morning wire on today's
episode the report on sarah palin suing
the new york times that episode is
available right now on apple spotify or
wherever you listen to podcasts make
sure to tune in i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliott feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover and our production manager
is pavo wiedowski associate producer
bradford carrington editing is by adam's
high events audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is by fabiola
christina production assistant jessica
crand the ben shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire
john bickley here daley wire
editor-in-chief wake up every morning
with our show morning wire on today's
episode international tensions escalate
over ukraine sarah palin faces off
against the new york times in court and
activist groups seek to unmask
charitable donations
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire
bye